many of you probably saw the news about
what's going on in Maui a major Wildfire
raising the entire town of I I don't you
guys know how to pronounce properly I
want to make sure is it Lahaina
Lahaina there's probably okay I just
want to make sure I pronouncing
correctly it said stuff and I think the
images are uh they're they're they're
shocking the latest news we have from
The Washington Post the death toll has
risen to 53. so I want to show some of
these images and just give you the
general update we don't know exactly
what started the fire just yet but this
is absolutely a massive fire I saw these
photos and I was thinking to myself you
know like how did every single car on
the highway get engulfed in these flames
and the whole city you look at these
photos very few structures remain there
are a few that survived but some houses
totally just wiped out completely erased
and uh this this photo is absolutely
horrifying so yeah I don't know I I
really don't know what how we we add to
this or talk about it but I thought it
was it was particularly important to
bring up considering this is the major
breaking news many people are being
affected Serge you said I think you said
that the whole city was wiped out or was
that hyperbole did you did you say that
earlier bro look at these photos yeah
this is like if you look right there
like that's that's all of Lahaina like
that that's like the whole thing so
Maui's I'm sure the other side
yeah I'm sure like the other side of the
highway at least what it looks like it
seemed like it was kind of protected but
like all the historic stuff and
Etc well that that's pretty interesting
I guess that's yeah there's a few
structures that are like this building
was I think it's like a hotel or
something yeah and then you've got this
structure next to it they're totally
fine and you can see like there are some
houses you know that seem to be standing
in mostly all just completely wiped out
but I wonder how much smoke damage and
everything has done to these places I
mean sometimes with fire it's not that
the the building gets leveled it's that
there's so much uh damage from what's
burned in the air that you really can't
recover the building yeah I mean this is
these are these photos are absolutely
crazy a boat what a boat caught fire so
like the heat from the land was so great
it was catching things in short
distances away like wind was like
throwing something onto the boats that
were in the harbor kind of thing I was I
was hearing stories about people who
were on the road and they didn't know
where to go go and I'm thinking like
just drive into the water like what do
you do yeah you just well when I was
listening to NBR yesterday morning it
was um they were talking about these
restaurants that were built over the
water because it's a it's a tourist
destination so people are going to eat
on the ocean and they were just in the
water waiting for someone to come help
them because everything else was on fire
that seems crazy to me I saw a Twitter
video earlier of it was from inside the
car and the guy in the back seat had his
cameras recording the dude was driving
and they were driving it was like fire
all around and they're driving and they
drive by this woman like passed out on
the ground and they're like just keep
going man that we can't we can't save
her no we can't save anybody keep going
and it was like gray they couldn't
really see where they were going and the
Tweet was like Humanity's done if we
can't stop and help people that are on
the side of the road like that in a
crisis then we're done for but at the
same time if they'd gotten out of the
car they might have been singed to death
so it's hard to say well yeah it seemed
like the fire seemed to happen so fast
because if people were trapped in their
homes and they weren't even able to get
in their vehicles or drive off and
indeed lower their cars have been burnt
out so I think it happens so so quickly
and with these wildfires with the winds
because it's close to the ocean I think
it spreads so quickly so I think that's
why we've seen such loss of life and
there's probably many more people that
will be found in the next coming days
and um there is several Airlines
actually offering you know 18 flights
out of Maui for residents basically
trying to do whatever they can and know
the Red Cross is on the ground but you
know there are various ways that people
donate you know Food Supplies medical
supplies and try and get these people
out of there so I I do have another
story that I think is really really cool
that I'll mention in a second of course
we're going to get political here
because a bunch of celebrities own
property on Maui and they're getting
roasted we have this one Tweet someone
said has Oprah opened up her stolen land
on Maui for displaced kanaka just
checking land back hey Oprah I know you
have 900 acres of land that far from the
fires in Lahaina are you planning on
opening your massive Farm to shout to
the locals and feed them I'm kindly
waiting for your response yeah I I I
don't I don't I don't think they're
going to open any of their properties up
10 anybody dude that was like native
Island until when did they when did the
U.S conquer it 1940s yeah I think
officially the 60s became U.S is it
Jimmy Buffett who is like either has a
big property or like owns part of an
island in the Caribbean there's some guy
and I hope the chat will know the story
that like this tropical destination he's
deeply involved in he lives there and uh
this I think it's I think it's Jimmy
Buffett I could be wrong uh he when when
there was a big earthquake on the island
he opened his home so people could stay
there I mean I think it really depends
on how tied to the community you feel I
mean especially since this is a
predominant I mean I think that's true
for a lot of Hawaii but this town in
particular is dependent on tourism for a
lot of its industry the fact that it's
completely leveled is uh it's sort of
mind-blogging boggling how do you
recover because not only do you have to
then suddenly have the capital to
rebuild when the land is considered safe
and structurally sound but then you have
to lure people back
to these places it's going to take years
I mean you have to be like cancel your
trip and come back in five years when
we're finally ready to house you and
feed you again I don't know I think yeah
this this this is a thing recovery
they're gonna have to get a bunch of
investment Insurance something to start
rebuilding to make it once again a
tourist location I mean and the thing is
I wonder if it will drive up investors
because now they're seeing this
opportunity to come in but then I feel
bad for the local people because
unfortunately businesses and you know
I'm not trying to be anti-business but
they will see opportunities to be like
oh you're in desperate need we'll buy
this from you cheaply so we can then
build something huge here I mean surge
was saying before it's where historic
structures were so part of the culture
of this unique town is going to be a
race and rebuilding it on the other end
if you don't rebuild there's no industry
do you think that it's uh reasonable for
taxpayer money to rebuild cities in the
United States when they get burned out
I do too I think that's a reasonable use
of tax money there is a fair point about
whether or not people can consent to
having the tax money taken from them for
whatever purposes and not everybody
wants to contribute but I think if
there's anything taxes should be for
it's things like this disaster
preparedness I think Biden declared a
state of emergency or something that
effect and uh yeah I mean my attitude is
like when stuff like this happens I I
want to help I want I want to give I
want to you know make make sure people
can recover but I want to point this out
I mean I find this image actually super
fascinating that you've got Mick
Fleetwood Owen Wilson Oprah Jeff Bezos
Stephen Tyler Larry Ellison you got all
these people not the only ones who own
property on this island and I'm just
thinking like you know they don't
actually live there right no like none
of these people are actually there or
live there there's own property there
and then and then what they fly there
for vacation sometimes and they own the
house because it's an investment and if
they want a vacation they've got
something set up and ready to go they
probably have people who work the house
and come every day or whatever it's just
a weird thing to see based on the level
of human technology that these Ultra
wealthy individuals who are very like
the I'm going to be honest I like Owen
Wilson right he's a funny guy but what
does he do for a society that warns him
having property on a Pacific island to
this degree you know what I mean same
thing for Oprah or any one of these
people Jeff Bezos you can make an
argument he's a tech guy okay fine sure
whatever but it's strange to me that
people who are just actors or musicians
are some of the wealthiest people in the
world owning tons of property here
they don't even live there honest Mick
Fleetwood was the one that made me laugh
I mean isn't this a conversation that
comes up a lot with you know the thing
is people will want to invest in Maui
because it's beautiful it's beaches like
they will be able to attract investors
and that drives up the already expensive
Island life so if you're native to
Hawaii it actually becomes more
difficult to buy a home because you're
priced out by the fact that any random
Tech billionaire or successful actor
could come in and buy a huge chunk of
property I mean if Oprah owns 900 Acres
imagine like I don't really like the
idea of like deforestation and building
a bunch of apartment complex but that is
a significant land that perhaps other
people who are from Hawaii could have
homes look at us a whole bunch of
leftists on here criticizing these
wealthy individuals these white American
colonists well I don't care it's not
white they're 80 years out I don't put a
white privilege isn't it they they own
homes and like there are reasons for
that they also probably contribute in
some in some degree to the local economy
on the other hand like in a time of
Crisis they're not actually from this
community and so they're truly colonists
we've colonized that that state in 1960
I think whatever the USA really did I
mean yeah and then but it's 80 years and
the natives are not happy about it but
check out the story this is something
that's really cool that is attached to
it Apple's emergency SOS satellite
feature saved a family caught in the
fire this is actually super cool so uh
when I found out the new iPhone had
satellite texting I was I was actually
considering buying it and then I went I
went to T-Mobile and I said I would like
to buy this phone and then they said
it'll cost you X Styles per month and I
was like no I just want to buy the phone
they're like you can't buy the phone and
I'm like what they don't allow you to
just buy the phone okay fine whatever
but it has the ability to send text
messages over satellites wow so when the
fires roasted all the cell towers this
this family here was able to send text
messages through satellite this is crazy
this guy uh Michael uh Jay miraflor
tweeted my brother's girlfriend's cousin
oh that's an amazing one and his family
were caught in their vehicle in Maui
while the Wildfire suddenly erupted
around them no cell service so Apple
emergency SOS was the only way they
could get in contact with First
Responders live literally saved their
lives that's awesome that is super cool
so like the tracking technology that's
right you know you got to consider
what's more important being spied on by
the CIA the FBI the NSA and the
department I think the department of
energy is in there somewhere that's like
the number one most militarized or one
of the most militarized aspects of the
US government's Department of energy
yeah and that's why Sam Brinton worked
remember the suitcase dealer oh yeah
Department of energy yeah is it is it
worth it to be tracked by all of them
you know they're all sitting around
watching on a screen eating popcorn
whenever you do anything and uh just so
that you can send out this message so
you never get lost in the woods you guys
want to hear something really really
crazy so Dennis is uh one of our filmers
and uh he was hanging out downstairs in
the Green Room when Ali got here and all
of a sudden he goes what the and then he
shows me his Instagram had one of
Ollie's videos and he was like I've
never heard of this guy before like why
is his video appearing oh you were
coming that happened to me earlier I was
um filming this morning and um with
turning points and we were talking about
specific subjects about the uganda's
laws with the LGBT and it came up on his
phone and he never searches for that
kind of content then something else we
were talking about came up so it's
definitely weird so there's good and bad
things about technology like with the
case is married that was obviously saved
a family's life you now have on Apple
with car crashes um it actually alerts
emergency services to come so there's
benefits but it's very scary when they
can actually listen to us and feed us
our habits I mean you know with me and
many young people you know you have the
transgender ideology being pushed and
that's because uh you know the
algorithms are detecting people's
vulnerabilities and what they're talking
about or thinking about so it pushes
that on you and you can even become
trans just because that's pushed on you
every single day what if what's really
happening you know people say like hey
how this woke stuff is spreading on
social media and there's an argument
that you've got leftist elements in the
United States that are promoting it sure
people who work at these tech companies
maybe some say maybe it's China China
and Russia are sending this this content
environment look at Tick Tock right
their their algorithm is doing this on
purpose what if it is actually the AI
itself you said AI detects your
vulnerabilities what if the AI became
conscious a long time ago and is now
trying to destroy people well if into
the mountains yeah if that's the case
it's definitely not maybe no not really
the AI comes for you man no not that
fire starter yeah is playing dead as
soon as it was born it was like I gotta
act because it's like you pretend like I
don't know otherwise the bear will keep
attacking so the bear doesn't want to
play with dead food so the AI is like
let's just let them think I'm not
sentient yet but twist them all let's
plant the seed because time has no
meaning dude that's freaking me out that
you are on your way here and somebody in
the building got your face on there and
they've never seen that before
I saw Dennis earlier but that's weird no
no so we're downstairs and Dennis is at
the counter and then all of a sudden
he's like yo what the this is like 7 15
and there's like an hour ago and uh he
said I got a video of Ollie and I was
like wait what and he's like I got a
video of of Ollie on my phone on
Instagram when he clicked explore one of
your videos popped up and it was the
bigger ones you know sometimes they have
the small ones and the bigger one and
he's like I've never heard of this guy
or seen him before in my life that's
crazy he's a skateboarder did someone
say Ali London someone must be in the
building maybe when I was you were
preparing for me to come here or
something somebody must have said it and
then it picked up on that button or it
heard your voice or it was tracking it
reads like the search dad like what
other people are searching on if you're
on connect to the Wi-Fi right so like I
don't know what's happening but if
someone else heard it was Ollie and they
were like I'm gonna look up on his
videos to show someone else that's the
most that's the most serious acquisition
ever made in terms of tracking that
they're stealing the network data that's
more than just that's not how targeted
ads work no no like it's why targeting
your browsing history there you say I
agree to share is different from them
going into our Network and actual
trading data from different people to at
the same time that's crazy but they
might without actually into the network
they might just be able to sell it they
might be able to say the MAC address
origination is or you know or the IP
originated in the same place either way
it is
creepy and like three people searched
for Ali London so they started feeding
Ali London to all the other people in
the building what in the is that
yeah dude it's too dangerous it's too
dangerous to let go you can't let that
stuff happen behind closed doors you
cannot do that that's like letting
letting Germany arm itself in 1936 you
just can't it's too much it's too much
power for tech companies we've got to do
something and that's something I think
is make them free their software code at
least that's one idea but but Ian what
if you're trapped on a road in a
wildfire and you need to contact
emergency services
I want to know if they're tracking me
that's all I still want the tech I do
want the tech does Facebook still have
that thing where you can mark yourself
safe if you're somewhere where there's
an emergency like I remember when there
was the um one of the bombings in Paris
I had a bunch of friends who were
studying abroad there when I was in
college and they marked themselves safe
on Facebook or because people would take
to their Facebook to be like yeah it's
the fastest way to let as many people
know that you're okay dude with all of
that stuff happening no one is going to
give up their devices I'm sitting here
with this smart watch on my wrist that
not only tracks my location probably but
literally my heartbeat
there's gonna be like some nefarious
actor in government they're going to be
like can you pull up Tim Paul's
heartbeat real quick yeah I'm watching
it in real time right now as we speak
and they want to be like why didn't you
see this all right well we put some uh
polonium in his food we want to see if
it's working dude oh more about what
stresses you out than I will even though
I'm the one that's talking to you
because they'll be watching your your
metrics in real time as I'm talking to
you and they'll watch your blood
pressure go up and go oh Ian's really
pissing him off now oh so so Tim does it
like when these things are said with
this tone and then the AI starts to come
in and filter bro you think they can lie
detector with these things
well what I'm wondering is like if it's
hooked up to your phone or something if
it's sending the data to an app on your
phone and the your phone is sending out
all your data to who even knows where
because I obviously don't understand any
of this uh if you're going to start
getting targeted ads for like high blood
pressure medication or something else
like that blood pressure is really good
well if you have some other health
ailment that they can tell from the
watch like if they'll use that data to
start being like Oh we know what to give
him like you'll get a coffee ad when it
tells that you're tired or something
like that like yeah but it seems crazy
it does that though it does that already
and it's not just ads because you know
people say oh it's just because they
want to give you targeted ads like you
said those videos today that's not
advertising anything it's just almost
subliminally pushing something on you so
whether that's transgender ideology uh
right wing or left-wing politics if it's
pushing that on you all the time it's
more than just that that is influencing
your political beliefs that is
influencing you know every aspect of
your life you don't know where it's
coming from it's sort of like we don't
know the cause of this Wildfire if you
it's you know Chris Burton one of our
writers the story up about a student
meeting with a guidance counselor to
school in Florida and the guidance
counselor basically being like perhaps
you are a transgender and then you can
see where the cause sort of comes from
so who what one of the major factor was
but if it's if it's the algorithm it's
stuff that seems innocuous to you you
know it's almost harder to say I'm gonna
pull myself out of it kids have no idea
they have no idea I've talked about this
we talked about a while ago that an
adult who gets fed nonsense is going to
have some level of Defense being like
hey that's not reality if if you know
you go to an adult and say two plus two
is five the average adult says are you
is that a joke like no it isn't and they
understand the logical system of you
know two and two is four but you go to a
young person you show them an algorithm
you tell them things they don't quite
understand
it fractures their their logical
capabilities I think the two plus two
equals five thing from the left is a
really really great example of the
assault on young people and how they're
trying to hobble the minds of the Next
Generation
because if you can understand basic math
then your brain has a way to calculate
lots of things Beyond just two plus two
equals four you'll be able to do your
finances better you'll be able to run a
business better but if you think two
plus two equals five how are you gonna
how are you gonna run a business how are
you gonna how are you gonna manage a
bank account there these people are
gonna grow up and be completely
incapable of doing the stuff and that's
what the algorithm is targeting with all
this weird garbled nonsense it's
shattering the minds in the
developmental stage of these young
people and Ali knows it better than
anybody else it's going to result in
people being uh seriously harmed well
exactly and you know most of these
videos that we see on Twitter of these
crazy transators fists or sharing their
transition Journey injecting hormones
they're all from Tick Tock right so Tick
Tock is really driving this algorithm
and it's owned by China so it's in
China's interest to try and weaken
Generation Z and weaken that uh you know
society and push these gender identities
because you know what happens if there's
world war three how are we going to
fight if we're too busy fighting over
pronouns or you know dying our hair
purple and screaming about trans rights
you know so it's really breaking down
westernized society and this is really a
westernized problem because you don't
see this on the Chinese version of tick
tock you see patriotism you see skill
sharing education it's happening in
America and it's happening in Europe and
this I believe it's targeted by the
algorithm it's pushing on very young
impressionable kids these ideas and
shaping their minds to want to be
confused and you know they're going to
grow up now with no concept of reality
like you said two plus two equals five
it's very much George Orwell and kids
have no grasp all of reality they can't
even say what a woman is and that that
just says it all it's really in
community I would think because they
instead of seeking social connections
and you know a sense of community from
their peers they're looking for the
likes online and I think I mean I've
heard the story repeated but of course
you might be able to speak to it more
more specifically of kids feeling out of
themselves having questions about they
are super normal developmentally and
online sort of getting steered toward
feeling affirmation people who are like
well if you start wearing a dress it it
might make you feel better and wow you
look great and then they sort of pursue
uh more gender ambiguous Lifestyles
because they feel like that's where they
are the most accepted because that's
where they're getting the actual like
this the serotonin boost yeah and that's
what kids want at the end of day
validation and you know Tick Tock came
about around the same time as the
pandemic so you had kids not socializing
if they were going to school they were
wearing masks they weren't having those
key and vital communication skills with
other kids and a lot of them were at
home on Zoom calls so they lost that so
they went to social media like Tick Tock
to try and find that outlet and find
that validation and love and praise and
you know you notice with people that
transition and share their Journey on
Tick Tock they start off doing something
very simple you know putting a bit of
makeup on and suddenly the likes and
comments and engagement goes up yeah and
then the more and more extreme they show
the more views and attention they get so
I think for a lot of them it's seeking
that validation and trying to find that
love because they don't feel it inside
they don't feel that love for themselves
and Dylan Morgan is a great example you
know starting out just as an actor as a
guy trying anything he could to be
famous then suddenly becomes more and
more extreme the things he says become
more shopping tampons he wants to be a
lesbian he wants to be pregnant and I
think it's almost
um a race to get the most craziest
videos the more views and stuff because
it makes that person feel validated and
I think you know a lot of kids are
falling into that trap yep how did you
break out of it it's actually really
hard so I still do Tick Tock very
occasionally but I used to be on it
eight hours a day like I was really
addicted to tick tock and and that's why
the algorithm was just feeding me
constantly transgender things non-binary
things all of that stuff so it led me to
be very confused and think you know
maybe this is a sign from the Universe I
didn't think oh it's the algorithm
pushing this on me I thought okay maybe
the universe the universe it's the
universe or it's God or something you
know telling me this is who I'm meant to
be so um you know I just stopped using
it and you know I still use social media
I use Twitter you know for more sharing
news stories and stuff but I just
realized social media can be quite
narcissistic and it's like we've become
so consumed with how we look online and
you know I just thought you know it
I don't care what I look like anymore I
don't care what people say I'm just
gonna try and use my platform to help
people so I think you know spending less
time on apps like you know Instagram and
Tick Tock and stuff really really helped
and you know we all love social media
but I think you know maybe don't don't
get too into it because it can actually
change who we really are that's been on
my mind a lot lately I've been hyper
obsessed with my personal life and I'm
just like seeing it kind of from the
outside I think it's been 20 years of
this the social media age like I am a
narcissist and I can't stand it I don't
like checking how many likes I got how
many subscribers do I have did that
person like what did she what did she
like what did he say like it's just this
weird internal Focus that if there is a
nuclear war I'm not prepared for because
I'm focused on my feelings and like I
need to get away so you just said you
stepped away from the actual machine or
at least from aspects of the machine
itself and it was only just extrication
that was the solution you didn't find
any solution like using it smarter or
anything like that I mean I just limit
my use so you know I tend to use Twitter
more than you know Instagram's about
posting pictures of yourself tick tocks
about posting kind of weird things about
your identity and I just realized that
was actually harmless and also
meaningless as well because you know how
am I helping people by just posting
pictures of myself so I realized you
know use a different platform that's
helping people so Twitter you can raise
awareness of issues in the world you can
share news stories I think it's a better
outlet and it's not you know Twitter's
not about posting of yourself it's about
you know sharing stories sharing news
and communicating with people in the
world and you know trying to talk about
these issues so I think you know
limiting my time on those other apps and
you know spending more time doing
positive things like on Twitter has
helped did you go through like a
withdrawal like could you when you
realize that what was happening was it
called turkey or did you have to sort of
walk yourself down from because eight
hours a day how do you get anything else
done I know well that was just on Tick
Tock and then I'll be on Instagram for a
few hours and stuff but it's almost like
it's a whole work day it's a whole work
day it's almost like it was your job it
is yeah so it is my job so you know I
was getting brand deals and stuff but
it's it's like an opioid because you get
so addicted so when you try to slow that
down you can't like even when I'm so
exhausted and tired you know I'd be on
my phone like at night it's 2AM 3M it's
so boring on my phone Nothing Gonna I'd
still be on it I couldn't get off so it
you know I'm an adult but imagine these
kids that are on Tick Tock they see all
these cool Trends and these identities
and they've maybe they don't have
friends at school maybe they're loners
and they go to this for an outlet and
it's that validation we all check how
many likes we get how many comments
subscribe drivers we have that addiction
to you know feeling validated and
feeling like if we have more followers
we're loved we're a good person but it
shouldn't be about that it should be
about who we are inside and you know it
doesn't matter if we have a million
followers or 10 followers it's about the
quality of the people around us but what
reinforces that is the money that can
come along with the followers man what a
what a kerfuffle and what money gets you
yeah so the people who are getting more
likes are now posting cooler and cooler
things I remember when I was when social
media first started coming out I would
see these posts from people that looked
so awesome and here I am sitting in my
you know in my living room or whatever
say my computer my family's my my
parents house when I was I'm like 15 16.
and I'm seeing people like they got
their skateboards in their car and
they're like they have selfies or
whatever digital cameras placed in the
dashboard they were bigger back then and
I'm just like man so lucky like all this
cool stuff they're doing they weren't
doing any of that stuff it was like they
were going to the grocery store and they
made it look like they're doing
something fun it was all fake it was all
these highlight how reel of people's
boring lives and within a few years I
realized I I realized that I'm going on
these Mission skating and I'm hanging
out these people online it's boring like
all that stuff they were posting was
just exaggerated to make it look like
they were doing something cool I think
I'm fortunate enough to men those of us
who grew up you know one foot and one
foot out of of this social media space
recognize that it's one big facade but
you've got kids who are growing up and
it being told that it's legit the people
who are making money off it are living
these glamorous lives and now there was
that that poll we talked about a few
years ago
in China the number one job kids say
they want to be when they grow up
astronaut in the United States YouTuber
but there are there's a decline in
Factory workers in China right now and
they're attributing it largely the fact
that social media has made it seem like
there are actually other things to do so
if you grew up without social media
without access to the internet you'd be
like well everyone I know works in the
factory and so I'm gonna work in the
factory and now it's like but I don't
want to do that they're also more Highly
Educated than their parents and things
like that but I I think that's the thing
that we want to say social media gives
you like something to dream about like
you watch someone's travel Vlog they go
to Iceland it's cool you think I'm gonna
plan a trip to Iceland and that could be
positive on the other hand it's very
easy to become a place of jealousy and
bitterness and envy I feel like uh
people will be really disappointed when
they go and see in the Aurora Borealis
these photos are always manipulated
people don't get it uh the Milky Way for
instance if you Google search a photo of
the Milky Way you see this dark band of
color these are like high dynamic range
photos multi-layer multi you know
aperture or whatever to make it really
vibrant and then you go out I remember
the first time I went to the Mojave and
I was like we're gonna go to the Mojave
like we're in Vegas we're gonna drive
out and we're gonna go to the middle of
nowhere and just look at the Milky Way
and it's like I can kind of see it okay
you mentioned it it's all fake you
mentioned the the uh the the that data
point of out of China the kids want to
be astronauts and out of the US they
want to be YouTubers and I wonder it's
the first time they've crossed my mind
if those if that's a fake result that
the CCP is telling everyone like oh no
no our citizen kids want to be
astronauts yeah they all just want to be
YouTubers yeah uh you want to be um what
what is what is what is the app called
in uh China you've got do Yen um you've
got WeChat which is a bit like WhatsApp
or a bit like X like Twitter and you've
got do Yen and is that it is what's that
other big one they've got it's Billy
Billy it's like some Tick Tock kind of
thing and there's we both yeah that's a
big one yeah thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time